for nearly 40 years peter has been
rescuing swans
but recently his rounds have taken a
more sinister turn
[Music]
after finding seven dead swans in this
ring peter alerted the authorities after
hearing concerns
that as the uk battles one virus another
could be reigniting
avian flu has been linked to a number of
deaths of wild birds over recent weeks
we ought to be worried we don't know
whether
this virus can travel from a dead body
of a swan
into the humans and i suppose i really
ought to take advice on that
um and i will do because it'd be silly
to
carry on regardless if there's a real
danger to our own lives others aren't
taking any chances
one veterinary hospital in
worcestershire told sky news they've
shut their doors after a suspected
outbreak there
once a dead bird is found they're
reported to the government
officials come along to recover them and
then go on to test them
this virus mutates it attacks the bird's
nervous system
causing them all kinds of neurological
symptoms
the department for environment food and
rural affairs have placed five premises
across the uk
including nature reserves and poultry
farms under strict biosecurity measures
the uk chief veterinary officer is
concerned and says these outbreaks
are reminiscent of 2017. biosecurity and
enhanced scrupulous biosecurity is
absolutely the best protection and and
housing is one of the actions that we
can take in that
so so that's the last time and we saw
this kind of high level of infection
and i guess they across the continent we
watch what's happening there closely
they're seeing the same lots of cases
being confirmed in
the netherlands particularly they get a
lot of wild birds and so while that's
happening
and my concern level remains really high
public health england say the risk to
human life and food contamination
is very low it's not known how these
swans died
but another disease whether affecting
animals or humans
is the last thing anyone needs
ashnaharenag sky news in newport south
wales